welcome in this video playing drooling
baby from Poland snow right and drooling
baby okay so check let's play it again
the bogo yeah I really played it so much
over the last couple of years in the
wake of my book project that I really
want to go for some else some other
openings but that's what I'm chalant Lee
knowing best but i guess i will i will
stop playing that in the in the blitz
games me not entirely but as a main as a
main opening because I'm I want to see
some some other position types so when
were quite sure what what else then go
to shoot for but want some some some
other some other position types okay
mmhmm yeah that's not very attractive to
me almost here why it is just a little
bit better
hmm maybe this is kind of okay but nice
gotta form
I was thinking at for now but not I have
to otherwise that that didn't make any
sense at all the whole kind of play
check okay five hmm I just have to hope
that your five is not hitting me too
hard if I get one or two moves to
organize my position I'm fine okay
hmm isn't that okay I mean I understand
that two bishops are usually better than
two nights but my Knights have pretty
decent outposts and he falls hanging I'm
okay so can I take you for now we takes
you for it's there a big problem with it
don't see it up I really don't see it
check check so I'm a pawn up that's good
it's not not an easy win by any means
but it's at least some material
advantage so how to do it I'm going to
go with the noid probably to e5 push up
at five now okay I'm going back so
that's probably okay
a four is an interesting move maybe I
should have done that already instead of
key is seven mmm okay let's go for it
undermining those pawns yes but it
should be a very nice structure that is
completely safe and I'm going over here
c 5 t 4
okay so came to do for ya that's no
reason not to check the space and now
they cannot move any of those pawns so
probably and get this going ok that's an
interesting question even if I go g4 h4
can start with 94 actually
96 and then taking c4 is I think a
simple and pretty good solution as I go
g4 and he goes back he might come around
with them which I shall him to take the
pawns I don't want that yeah I think
this is the easiest not not allowing any
pawns on that side of the board and just
take take the rest here check
so where to where to put it there's some
particularly good square I don't know
and probably not
I totally forgot about that move wow
it's pretty awful down 29 seconds that's
not good at all check check check check
check check mate okay this has sped up
at the end made it a little bit more
difficult than it needed to be yeah that
was probably a pretty bad position out
of the opening but it didn't work out
him so we should land and well ya hear
the engine actually things I'm okay
yellow just gives white a slight edge
with rook everyone mmm I think the
critical phase of the game is right here
I took on g3t chest takes yeah and he
air this is it was scared somewhere here
had to be the the the point yeah the
computer is merciless and goes e5 this
is one of those moves that you can
safely give two exclamation marks very
nice very nice if I take it 25 is just
devastating I can check but it doesn't
help and how do I cover this now
amazing we should be forced that's
essential by the way and nitrous sixes
still cannot hang on and here is Bishop
d7 well II five that's a fantastic
really fantastic move the engine gives
this as relatively best but I've
completely lost Wow yeah had this
feeling that there should be something
or why but II five is very tough I mean
in a blitz game you just take on g3 and
here again he 5v5 again it's again good
for whitey didn't do that I had this
feeling that this is letting me off the
hook yeah this is given by but stock
fish with the big advantage for white
yeah I can barely move here oops
yeah finish this is ken can end very
quickly here 85 that was the thing now
no I'm okay and now he has to go Bishop
f5 but you went here check Jim and here
I'm a porn up this is still not totally
clear but it helped me I think I'm this
a3 move helped me a lot especially here
now that you didn't react to that I
think yeah here black wins minus 1 point
4 I think that was technically okay and
there's this g4s may be easier but I
wasn't completely sure yeah I ok it's
actually actually rubbish what I'm
thinking because I mean I was I wasn't
sure if he might be can get to that porn
something like this but he never he
never ever gets them yeah give it this
is also winning it just I just made it a
little bit tougher than necessary check
I should just go back maybe that's
easier it's also minus 11
yeah so I didn't didn't screw it up i
just made a little bit more chan chan
take longer than the necessary but it
didn't endanger the overall mission to
win this game wow I was lucky though and
out of the opening I had huge problems
thanks for watching